-Our first guest tonight is
an Academy Award-
and Tony-nominated
actor, writer, and director
you know from films such as
"Training Day" and "Boyhood"
and the shows "The Good Lord
Bird" and "Moon Knight."
His documentary series
"The Last Movie Stars"
is streaming now on HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Ethan Hawke,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I love it. Looking sharp,
my man. Looking sharp.
-I'm about to go
on the "Louisiana Hayride"
with Hank Williams.
-I love it.
-By the way, that album cover
looks insanely cool.
-Yeah.
-Does it not remind you
a little bit of Khonsu
from "Moon Knight"?
I don't know
if you saw "Moon Knight."
-Yes, I did.
-But it's got
a little Khonsu vibe to it.
-We try very hard --
we always want to
also promote your work
when we promote
the guest drummer.
-I appreciate that.
I appreciate you
thinking about me
and I'm thinking about you.
-Yeah, it's very nice.
Hey, this is -- we've talked
about this, like, two years ago
how this project came across
your plate.
This is a wonderful six-part
documentary series
about Paul Newman --
-Can I stop you?
-Yeah, please.
-This has never happened to me.
My shirt is stuck on the thing,
and I'm kind of casually
pretending that it's not stuck,
but I got it off now.
Okay, go on. You were saying?
It was so interesting.
-It would've been so great
to go back and watch
you do the whole interview
where only --
you're only gesticulating
with one hand.
[ Laughter ]
So, Paul Newman
and Joanne Woodward,
this is about their career,
their romance.
It's wonderful.
It's great archival footage.
And how -- but how did it come
across your plate?
-Well, this wonderful producer
named Emily Wachtel,
she is really close with the
family -- been a longtime friend
and felt like it was really time
to make a documentary
about them.
They -- I guess
Claire Newman and I
actually went to the same
high school my senior year,
and so somehow
they thought of me.
I think they thought --
A lot of people
when they think of Paul Newman
and Joanne Woodward,
they have this, like,
"celebrity idea" in their head,
and I think the family really
wanted somebody to revisit them
as artists and actors
and as people
who dedicated their life
to the performing arts.
And they thought that I might be
the right person to do that.
I had no idea
what they were thinking about
or why they did it.
I mean, I literally was sitting
on the phone thinking,
"That sounds like so much work."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-I desperately
don't want to do this.
But I couldn't get the words
"no" out of my mouth, you know?
So I said, "Sure, yeah.
I'll do it."
And then there went
three years of my life.
-Yeah.
-Well, the payoff is very nice.
We thank you for your sacrifice.
-No, I did it because I love
them and I feel like...
Oh, I don't know. You could
talk about it for a long time.
But just the role
of heroes in our life,
of people
that we can look up to.
These are like
two white people
that were born with a lot
who did a lot with it.
They dedicated their life to
meaningful, substantive arts
and they did it with --
in the middle of having
a 50-year love affair
and they gave away
hundreds of millions of dollars.
They're part of -- I just admire
the way they lived their lives.
So, whenever you think it's not
possible to be a good person
and have a good time
and cut a lane for yourself
where you're actually
part of the solution,
it is possible,
and Paul and Joanne are proof.
-Yeah, they really are proof.
And it is really -- You know,
I think that, you know,
I was certainly aware of, like,
Paul Newman's Own, right?
Like, growing up as a kid,
seeing it at the super market.
I was like, "Oh, look," you
know, "that's,
you know...Butch Cassidy."
But I didn't quite realize
that, you know,
the breadth of their charity.
-Oh, you know, the thing is you
always hear this thing about
this billionaire who gave away
hundreds of millions of dollars,
but Paul and Joanne didn't have
hundreds of millions of dollars.
They gave away exponentially
more money than they kept,
and I think
that's really beautiful.
And the fact that they used --
That hadn't been done before,
to create a non-for-profit
company and to use his celebrity
to generate wealth and
opportunity for other people.
-You -- It's called
"The Last Movie Stars,"
and, you know,
the idea of what's celebrity
and how it's changed
and how it's harder to,
you know, achieve what they did.
But what made you -- You know,
obviously I think this was --
maybe Gore Vidal
had made the observation.
What made you choose it
as the title?
-I don't know. It caught my --
When I read Gore Vidal said that
they were the last movie stars
and what he meant was that the
last generation to come up
the same way the first movie
stars did through acting class,
through the studio system,
the hard-earned road
before -- You know,
back in a period
where there were a handful
of movies made a year,
it was a really big deal
to be in a movie.
Now there's, you know,
20 movies come out a weekend,
so it is different.
But when I first read it,
I thought,
"No, they're not movie stars.
They're actors.
Why would he think that?"
But I found that
it made me think the title,
so I thought,
"Well, that's a good title."
-Yeah.
-I don't really agree with it,
but I like it.
-I do really love anytime --
I always feel like it's a gift
not just to young actors
but people -- young people
in any field
who might not
feel sure of themselves.
Like, in this first episode
especially,
you see a Paul Newman who lacks
confidence and isn't sure.
-That meant the most to me.
I mean, 'cause you can't imagine
Cool Hand Luke being insecure.
-Yeah.
-I mean,
it just doesn't really --
But then you start picturing --
Paul Newman was in acting class
with James Dean
and Marlon Brando.
I mean, those are two of the
other students in the class.
Forget, you know, Geraldine
Page, Marilyn Monroe, Ben G--
I mean, the list is endless.
So he was not the best student
in that class.
And his life's journey,
which I find so inspiring,
is that he got better and better
and better and better,
whereas a lot of his peer group
gets burned out,
gets lost, gets confused,
gets crushed by celebrity,
whatever the different stories.
But he was definitely insecure.
Would change his shirt
three times a day
'cause he sweat so much.
-There's a screen test I guess
with him and James Dean
where he just looks...
He looks like a dork.
-The actor in you knows,
"Oh, wow, you're nervous."
He doesn't know
how to move his face,
kind of like me
on this show right now.
[ Laughter ]
And, no, it is.
I find it so charming to see
him, you know, with James Dean.
-Yeah, because you realize
it's a journey for everybody.
Nobody's born like the public
version of Paul Newman.
No one's born --
-I wish I was, but nobody is.
-Yeah. Alright.
I got a lot more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from Ethan Hawke, everybody.